well as you know I have been sounding
off for quite a while here on what I
perceive to be Bernie Sanders is
extremism on all manners of subject but
joining me on the line to discuss all of
this and a supporter of the Sanders
campaign is Arielle gulches the national
co-director of code pink a women led
organization working to end a u.s. Wars
and militarism Arielle thank so much
during the show really appreciate it
thanks so much for having me on and I
just have to challenge that idea of
Bernie Sanders as an extremist in fact I
would call him a moderate in many ways a
moderate compared to many of our most
economically successful European allies
and a moderate on even such things as
militarism and the israel-palestine
conflict okay so why don't we start with
the foreign policy stuff because code
pink is an organization that is really
directed at foreign policy correct we
are so organization that focuses on
foreign policy right so let's start on
the foreign policy front so just from
your perspective ideally what should the
United States be spending on the
military what should our military
presence look like because you're you're
a Sanders supporter and you like Sanders
so what do you think America's military
spending should look like
well our Pentagon budget is enormous ly
bloated and we just authorized another
seven hundred and thirty eight billion
dollars for it
at the same time we continue to say that
we cannot afford to provide health care
for all of our citizens we continue to
say that we cannot provide decent
schools and not college education my
daughter herself is 17 she won't be 18
before the election but she is
personally campaigning for Bernie
Sanders because as a 17 year old with
SAT scores and a GPA that she is
enormous ly proud of one of the main
things that she has to consider when
looking at schools is what kind of
financial packages they have and what
she can afford this is outright shame
okay so so I'm happy so Ariel and I'm
happy to I'm happy to hear why you want
marginal cuts to the Pentagon but the
actual question was what would you like
the Pentagon budget to actually look
like how much money on a dollar basis
should the United States be spending on
the military well I am not a
presidential candidate so it's not for
me to release these numbers but there is
a people's budget out from the port
people's campaign a moral budget looking
at where our values are are our values
providing 3.8 billion dollars for Israel
to continue its unending occupation and
apartheid system for Egypt to continue
its brutal crackdowns on journalists
should we be continuing to support Saudi
Arabia the most gender segregated
country on the planet and who has
created the worst humanitarian crisis on
the planet or should we be lifting up
human right should we be lifting up at
providing such things as the children in
Yemen a place where a child under the
age of five so is I 10 minutes so this
is so the fundamental premise that you
seem to be supporting is that the United
States military presence and foreign aid
funding around the world has been of net
harm to people around the world and in
the United States in particular you
won't give me sort of a standard as to
what the US should be doing in foreign
policy instead of putting in dollar
terms let me ask it a third way okay
what should the US military be doing
abroad we should be working on our
concerns here at home that is exactly
the point that we should be pulling out
of the Middle East we should not be
mental we're just not gonna get an
answer to this question so the military
basically should should the military
should you be doing nothing basically
absolutely we should be closing our
military bases and I think we can begin
with the troop bringing the troops home
and out of Iraq and we should be ending
our foreign meddling in such countries
as Venezuela placing sanctions on
Venezuela we should be working on you
know I'm a little bit in agreement with
Donald Trump here or at least what
Donald Trump ran on a little bit of you
know how you ran on being an
isolationist I'm working on our needs
here at home and good god it is not well
that our thumb is broken okay I'm like
this question okay so you you just
mentioned for example Venezuela so let's
get down to a few brass tacks here you
say that America should be spending less
money on Venezuela we're not in fact
spending very much money on Venezuela we
have economic economic be meddling in
the affairs of other countries okay okay
so let's go back
all right we are meddling meddling in
the affairs of Venezuela it is bad to
meddle in the affairs of Venezuela
you're simultaneously calling for no
sanctions on Venezuela which is a
socialist dictatorship where people are
eating dogs but no saying but but we
should certainly have sanctions
according to you I mean you've made this
obviously very clear on the State of
Israel which you have termed an
apartheid state please explain why yes
sanctions on Israel no sanctions on the
socialist dictatorship of Venezuela
which by the way is a position that's
been supported by a bunch of people in
the Sanders campaign as well absolutely
so I want to clarify that I do not
support broad-based unilateral sanctions
on the common people such as what's
happening in Iran where people including
Jews in Iran cannot get life-saving
cancer medication what I support our
military sanctions and I absolutely
think that it's time to place military
sanctions on Israel okay so let's talk
about this for a second just as a
premise so we can talk about this with
kind of all our cards on the table will
you condemn terrorism Hamas in the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad terror groups
I condemn terrorism across the world but
I think we need to begin in our
condemnation of terrorism by ending our
ties with the brutal Saudi Arabia
government no no I ask a very specific
question I mean like specifically Hamas
and Palestine because it's like a very
easy yes or no but I am quite critical
of both Hamas and the PA numerous times
they are incredibly repressive of their
own people time and again and that is
increasing rapidly and very
unfortunately to be fair you've actually
defended people who have been convicted
of terrorism offenses from Palestinian
Islamic Jihad on your Twitter feed we'll
have to discuss that later and you can
pull that up personally we can discuss
that on Twitter sure but where we should
be focusing our attention in this case
is the fact that Gaza has an over fifty
percent unemployment rate that does not
lift up a human right that does not help
the people of Gaza to reform their own
government any more than the brutal
sanctions we're placing on Iran are
helping the people of Iran to reform
their own government and we cannot deny
or ignore the imbalance of power between
Hamas and the PA and Israel so
Israel as the occupier under
international law of both the West Bank
and Gaza has obligations under
international law and that is where we
should be focusing and we could simply
begin by no longer supporting them with
military aid which is something that
Bernie Sanders has placed on the table
perfect okay so let me ask you a quick
question about Israel since you brought
Israel up does Israel have the right to
exist as a Jewish state Israel does
exist as it exists doesn't have a right
to exist as a Jewish state I don't
believe in a Jewish state because as a
Jewish state it privileges the rights of
one group of people over the other I
believe in freedom and justice and
equality for all people in whatever
solution that takes and those are the
values the growing values of young Jews
across the Merrit America which is
undeniable young Jews compared to their
older counterparts are by and large more
progressive less attached to Israel or
less blindly attached to Israel and more
committed to progressive values for
Americans here at home Israelis and for
Palestinians so I just want to thank you
for coming on and providing some clarity
so in this interview we've established a
couple of things one the US military
should be as close to not involved as
possible in the world in your view and
and this is these are all reasons why
you think that Sanders sort of reflects
these views - we shouldn't be imposing
sanctions on Venezuela or Iran but we
should be imposing sanctions on Israel
three that Israel does not have a right
to exist as a Jewish state in your view
and four that the United States should
be providing aid to the Gaza Strip which
is specifically governed by the
terrorists from Hamas so there would be
no other way for they had to get in then
via Hamas I want to point out that these
are not extreme views when we talk about
Jews across the world then your views
are and if we want to talk about
supporting terrorists Ben Shapiro I just
can't help but you know remember
unfortunately that both Nazis and
terrorists are inspired by you now I am
yet to have any mob here we go okay so
and I will point out Ariel that by the
same standard that you're using which is
that apparently there was one
there was one evil anti Islamist
terrorist in Canada who viewed my
Twitter feed a lot I will notice that
you are supporting a candidate one of
whose followers shot up a bunch of
Republican Congress people at a baseball
game I have never blamed him for that
and it is wildly unfair to do so for
anybody who has millions of followers I
do Ariel I really thank you so much for
your presence it's always pleasure to
have you on it's fun to have the debate
and thanks for coming on good to talk to
you good to talk with you
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content